you've been married how many years now
18 18 years you have four kids all right
yeah that gets around in the cards and
you said you have four kids valentine's
Day is tomorrow yes is it hard to have a
romantic moment even with your wife when
there's four children running around the
house you know we have a new development
in my house so I have three sons and
then a daughter my middle son came home
quite recently and I think they just had
a sex education class
and there are others who I can tell yeah
awkward yeah well does he he's 12 okay
and he came home and and said mom do you
and dad have sex and my wife quite
rightly said yes and then he said in
this house
[Applause]
so so now we're just concerned that
there's there's ears at doors sure I'm
not touching his mother
yeah well also are there others in the
family talking mean younger ones getting
a cuz they're gonna hear from the 12
year old that's what happened yeah well
my 8 year old who who doesn't know what
sex is but happens to somehow have
connected undulation with the fact that
sex happened so he he every time my my
middle son is traumatized by the idea of
mommy and daddy having sex my youngest
son goes round going
[Applause]
clearly has no idea how this works so
you pick those all together and you're
here on your way
you